sona obsession has taken a temporary
leave of absence she's been out
promoting her her new book world's worst
assistant
terrific terrific effort by sona it's a
really funny book it's it's out there
and she's
she's flogging that uh she'll be back
soon but this is an opportunity sona's
not here which means we can dish on sona
and we can be completely honest and to
help us do that
is sona's own assistant who pretty much
does everything
since the minute he was hired because
well if you read sona's book you'll find
that she never really was my assistant
and soon she'll be back continuing not
being my assistant
um but uh david hopping has taken over
david you're a occasional voice here on
the podcast first of all i'd like to
know
uh how did you get this job how did you
get the job of being sona's assistant so
i interned for you back in 2014
then i was a tour guide on the warner
brothers a lot for like two years and
like once a month i would just come just
like walk through your office just to
make sure people remembered who i was
and then so you were running tours on
the lot
were you ever present when a tour
saw
uh me i was walking along i was getting
a tour once and you drove by on a golf
cart people must have just
lost their minds i actually it did work
out perfect because i had two fans that
were like huge fans of yours and then
you waved at them and then i got tipped
because they were excited that they saw
you so wouldn't i get some of that money
i would think i would no it doesn't work
okay first of all i was sort of being
doing a joke it's i'm glad that it
actually turned out that they were
really excited but i remember the tours
would come around every now and then and
i would always feel like i had to have
performance energy whenever a tour
passed i know that not everybody felt
that way there were other celebrities
they'd be like
meh tour and they wouldn't give anything
right yeah some hated the tours yeah
yeah i probably shouldn't say who no no
you probably probably shouldn't say
later
interesting i'm just guessing if you're
a pretty little liar you don't want to
see a tour yeah some of them were really
nice of course we're not naming names
but occasionally there'd be a pretty
little liar maybe one little liar i mean
literally ran away from my cart i was
like driving and she had a security
guard stop my cart while she like
sprinted away
okay we're not again
we can't get in trouble because we're
not identifying which pretty little liar
ran away from the the tram taking
tourists like the biggest pretty little
liars fan so then i was trying to come
up with any excuse and i was like oh i
think she's in costume like she kind of
spoilers maybe
i don't know right
she's late for a heart surgery
[Laughter]
something like that that makes her seem
noble she usually stops and says hello
but uh
she's late for dialysis
first of all their name is pretty little
liars so you you'd expect that kind of
behavior yeah
so anyway um that was your job then sona
brings you on board yeah to be an
assistant right mm-hmm so i assisted her
and marie weber at the time who was jeff
ross's assistant right to basically just
run
errands for you and jeff right get me my
basic uh i'll get your groceries i would
take your car to get washed
okay
um you got me groceries i don't remember
that every monday i think someone is i
think someone else was using you to get
groceries and saying these are for conan
i don't think so i i will never forget i
got the grocery list and on it it said
whole carrots because conan likes to
peel them and eat them like bugs bunny
oh my god that's just not true oh of
course it is it is not true of course it
is no i would tell you if that was true
but
what an insane thing to write about i
think i still have the list from 2016.
right did it have my various creams and
emollients that i need no various
potions never got you that powders
elixirs
bombs it did have roasted turkey
poultices i ate a lot of turkey back
then lean uh lean protein i liked
because i was a lean comedy machine
now i'm a bloated parody of myself oh
wow it got dark so quickly i'm merlin
brando at the end of apocalypse now
the horror the horror swallow the bug
yeah i'll explain what that is too later
i also asked off so the day that i got
hired i asked off for four weeks before
i started because i was going to europe
the next day wait you got hired to
assist conan o'brien and you said my
first request is to blow this off for
four weeks oh yeah i do that i yeah you
should you really should have done it
um no at the interview they told me i
could start and so i just said well i
leave tomorrow for four weeks is that
okay and sona said it was fine okay yeah
sure sona said and she said she said
that's a coincidence cause i'm leaving
tomorrow for the caribbean for six weeks
that's something she would do oh great
we'll both be away
we'll look after conan i don't know
he'll find some turkey and carrots on
his own a freak was there any illegal
activity in your time with sona did she
ever encourage you to break the law in
any way because she's a little bit of a
rule breaker well i think it was illegal
then what what are we talking about well
the stealing
it wasn't stealing we never stole
anything together i don't think i don't
think but one of the first times i ever
tried weed
was
in your office
like literally in his office in my
office at warner brothers with sona
we this is a safe space right like we
can't get in trouble oh yeah there's no
there's no recording device here in the
podcast studio yeah but like what's said
on the podcast like you can't get fired
for right
let's hear it and i'll let you know okay
so wait you're in you're in uh my office
at warner brothers studio it was a day
where you did a double show so you
always give like you know like there's
always a dinner break
and you were downstairs getting ready
for the next show
and we went into your office and opened
up the window we did blow the smoke out
the window
this is where they shot goonies by the
way
this is a sacred place they shot
casablanca and more important to you and
sona goonies on your staves they shut up
they shot they shot uh casablanca was
not shot on my stage it was shot in and
around i think in a couple of locations
but uh
goonies you reefed up on the set of
goonies yeah david hopping well i'm
proud of you thank you
so much any tour that was going by would
you see smoke now did you did you get a
good buzz going not really i don't think
i did it right the first time you don't
always feel it yeah yeah i've tried it
many times and still nothing really
happens really yeah you probably have
such a firewall for any kind of brain
changing thing you know what i mean it
couldn't get it might be i might be uh
just a strong barrier um whenever they
give me a medication i need a lot of it
for it to have an effect and i've heard
that that's a red-haired thing really
that redheads need more of a medication
yeah that's actually he's joking
i think you need something
my
uh
so anyway that's a little digression so
wow so that's that's ballsy of something
my first bag of edibles was from sona
which kind of came from you because you
rewarded her when she watched like
whatever 50 episodes of friends yeah we
did a thing if we could because she
watched so much tv work i made a bet
that she couldn't watch 50 episodes of
friends and she did and i rewarded her
with her favorite thing uh a bag of uh
edible gummies she kind of just like
went through the hall as like the weed
fairy just like giving people edibles
getting you guys hooked yeah and she
could be a dealer yeah first one's free
mm-hmm
wow what uh i wonder if this is in her
book i don't remember i write her book i
don't know i don't think this part's in
there but other crimes are in her book
yes that's true now you're the assistant
not just for me
but for jeff ross as well because we've
really pared things down a bit here
so you're you're assistant to two of us
sona you're supposed to be assisting
sona but she's uh she's
off selling a book on a book tour and
the book's about how she screws around
all the time and you do all the work
so is that fair do you have any
resentment there no because someday you
get to write a book yeah yeah the
world's most average assistant
[Laughter]
all right well listen thank you and
please keep ratting her out because it's
important
because if she were here she's so loud
and so defensive she'd start yelling
over all of this and none of it would
get recorded
so this is really our chance
to get the the dirt on sona
you're a good man david hopping thank
you and again a quick plug for your
podcast what's it called uh back to the
best back to the best and it's about 90s
trivia 90s early 2000s nostalgia a lot
of disney channel um
yeah okay
so you're screwing around too well
no yeah okay yeah i know we have to wrap
but we sona did come on my podcast and
we waited till you went down to rehearse
your show once and then we had my friend
grace who i co-host with come in and we
sat in your office and recorded our
episode
this is unbelievable
unbelievable
i think it's like episode
15. i am the ultimate chump
i'm paying these people to get high in
my office record their own podcast my
therapist meets me in your office and we
do our sessions in there
and then your therapist bills me yes
all right well i guess i should be mad
at you but i'm just kind of impressed
thanks yeah so well done david hopping
well done